reading according to all known laws of
aviation ah narration of the reading now
reading kill a black yellow black Oh
black and yellow yeah let's shake it up
a little this is the movies first joke
and it's so lame you wonder how the rest
of the movie ever got made in the first
place another indication of this movies
terrible humor inside of two minutes
honey used as hair gel gargle and
deodorant bees honey laughs damn you and
a perfect report card all B's get ready
for an hour and a half of bee puns and
that's about it I help with bees have
cars more importantly how the hell would
bees have cars is this just an animated
version of all the things Jerry Seinfeld
likes like cars sneakers and dating
women that are way out of his league it
is Oh comedians in cars getting
paychecks okay I'm willing to buy that
these bees operate more or less like
humans only they retain most of the
characteristics of bees but there's a
competes area in this hive and it's
successful enough to take up a large
chunk of the front page of this paper
also shouldn't there be more concerned
over the frisbee hitting the hive must
have been like a giant earthquake these
guys parked the car and then it was
straight why they shouldn't need a car
by flying out of the car quite a bit of
pomp under the circumstances this thing
should be called pun movie and I don't
mean that as a compliment
I like puns I just prefer good ones are
we gonna pick our job today
I heard it's just orientation how the
hell did these assholes not know what's
coming where they seriously not informed
that they were gonna do beep what was
the point of school then that girl was
hot she's my cousin
yes we're all cousins casual reference
to the ramp and incest in this hive is
extremely casual the same job for the
rest of your life I didn't know that how
could you not have known that this is
something that would've been taught
since birth right this ride is pretty
stupid to begin with but using honey
instead of water for the flume is most
wasteful of honey and resistant to the
laws of physics and how honey works ha
ha nice Splash Mountain gag but where is
camera there's nothing that's mounted
anywhere near the slope to get this
angle also why is camera wait they
literally just said everybody knows just
think someone you die so how was this
asshole able to off seven other people
then himself
those are pollen jocks man this movie
sure is selective on what the main
characters do and don't know so they
know who the pollen jocks are but
nothing else about how honey is made I
think our cousins too distant distant
Alabama we going
900 a gate what do you think buzzy boy
wait so anyone can become a pollen jock
at a moment's notice I know the fly boys
are fuckin with Barry here but they're
also being serious about him leaving the
hive is this a breach of protocol
who knows anything about the rules here
I thought they were supposed to pick
their occupations that day right but it
seems like right after the corporate
lady made that announcement everyone
went their separate ways
Jesus I don't think this movie even
stopped to watch itself yeah go to start
calling everybody dogs man there's some
excellent 90s comedy in this 2007 movie
whenever a bee dies that's an opening
he's dead this goes on for some time
also if this is the case why rush to get
a job picked anyway Adam said the good
jobs would be taken but they're
constantly opening up what happened B
antenna our phones man they actually
make a ringing noise when you get a call
when but these guys are all checking
different things and are only checking
themselves not the entire fleet so this
is some really wasteful use of radio
waves my mouth I can't believe I'm out
why is this such a big deal at the
beginning of the movie Adam and Barry
were talking about their friend that was
killed by a squirrel
so apparently school-aged bees are able
to leave the hive but this is Barry's
first time also this shot suggests that
the bees immediately ascend to the
altitude of a New York City skyscraper
which is some serious beat these kites
are also being flown at or above the
height of a skyscraper despite a
complete lack of string or people
holding them
we have roses visual so was this the six
mile journey that the pollen jocks were
talking about yesterday they didn't even
leave the fucking Park movie completely
reinvent zombies pollinate flowers for
the sake of I guess maybe toy sales I'm
not sure why the guns had to be part of
the equation
to be honest also sure the firing of
suck guns in order to extract pollen
from flowers is apparently extremely
typical behavior and is completely
unnoticed by humans those aren't even
roses and your orders this morning
definitely indicated roses you're off
script chief dude seriously reaches up
to grab the frisbee that's surrounded by
a swarm of bees that's commitment
none of these bees get swatted to death
by any of these humans this
the coolest what is it I don't know what
I'm loving this color is seen not only
presupposes that experience pollen jocks
mistake tennis balls for flowers but
also that they'd never seen these in
Central Park
animated upskirting no lie the movie is
going to hinge on the first day out of
the hive guy getting stuck on a tennis
ball and not getting smashed by native
the ensuing tennis name circuit counting
how many times ib would be killed over
the last two minutes alone so I'm just
gonna guess it would be 32 what a sign
in the movie that many fucking sense not
only does he believe this why I was
table but he's also literally flying in
the rain while chanting this mantra made
it into a fold-out brochure what the
hell but I said Ken we're playing tennis
less than 2 movie minutes ago and all
we've seen is Barry get toss into a car
and fly into a window but they had time
to finish the game pack up and get all
the way home Barry and acts exactly how
I feel watching this movie
Jesus Vanessa was able to change clothes
and come up with a spread in less than
30 seconds goddamn time-traveling
Zellweger's covering up their goddamn
tracks it's at this point you start
realizing Vanessa might actually want to
this be I guess I've seen more egregious
product placement but definitely not
this cheesy coffee actually I would love
a cup setting aside the many and
practicalities of this interspecies
meet-cute how that would Barry drink a
cup of coffee or know what coffee is but
not like windows watermelon I thought
you said Guatemalan huh why would I
marry a watermelon
ladies and gentlemen Jerry Seinfeld
humans humans I can't believe you were
with humans and apparently no one
noticed that Barry was gone all day
despite the pollen jocks knowing
specifically when he was lost how'd you
get back poodle but the hive was within
sight of Bridget Jones apartment right
Barry could have flown home in a matter
of seconds do you know do you Jesus
Barry was out of the hive for an
afternoon but apparently is super
goddamn knowledgeable about humans I can
I will gladly volunteer to deny said
yearning be heart your yearning for a
human smoothie is dumber than stupid
he's in the pool I thought honey was
this super precious commodity so why did
the Bensons fill an entire fucking
swimming pool with it
Oh to be in the tournament of roses
that's every florists dream I knew a
florist once her dream was to turn a
profit in a calendar year I realize she
kind of weirded out yesterday when they
first spoke but isn't she just a little
too okay with talking to her newbie
friend on day 2
to normal in less than 18 hours ray
liotta private select I can only assume
this is a joke about Newman's own
products but Paul Newman's food label
donates every red cent a profit to
charity so I'm not sure why I would
deserve mockery and if it's not a
Newman's Own joke and it's just a famous
person started a honey business joke
then you'd have gotten a lot more Milan
try to using Jessica Alba here please
don't know about this this is stealing
how in the world would be he's not know
about this maybe your hive doesn't know
but bees talk to other bees right none
of them have ever seen a human
harvesting their honey he paints his
yellow stripes black but leaves his
yellow face and yellow sweater alone
because he is a beam and has no concept
of subterfuge and this is a stupid movie
fYI Abby is fencing with his stinger
against a human using a thumbtack this
biker can feel the drag difference when
a fucking bee lands on his backpack we
saw Mulan and then called Chris Rock and
said hey can we hire you to do like a
b-movie version of that voice I guess in
order to be a successful beekeeper one
must have a consuming hatred of bees
this is your queen that's a man and
woman's clothes that's a drag queen
instead of pointing out the dated humor
of a movie from way back in 2007 I'd
like to submit the question of how king
bee knows what a drag queen is wait
where the hell did berry good king spy
camera he didn't go back to his hi after
discovering the honey in the grocery
store so that means he just had it on
him while on its date with Vanessa which
brings up some even more disturbing
questions dating a cricket once in San
Antonio man those Crazy Legs
kept me up all night movie will simply
not miss a chance to throw in a
reference to some creepy crawly
interspecies insect intercourse nobody
works harder than bees telling that to
Michael chiquinha seriously movie B
Larry King is the best you could come up
with for this fucking cameo not Larry
Queen or Larry sting or anything
creative Larry bees have never been
afraid to change the world I mean what
about bee Columbus bee Gandhi but Jesus
quiet please actual work going on here
is that that same bee wait so the whole
bees can talk is just accept it now and
even though it's the first rule of
beat'em not to talk to humans Barry
phase zero repercussions for breaking it
I'm helping him sue the human race well
you want a flower shop so I'm guessing
you're a huge help
why but instead of flowers people are
given balloon bouquets now yep she's
right the last two weddings and three
funerals I went to all had balloon
bouquets and almost zero flowers you
know very this lawsuits a pretty big
deal that's why I'm mailing it at night
after preparing it myself and not even
once consulting a lawyer why is there a
jury shouldn't it just be a preliminary
hearing how did the jury even get
selected if this is the first day of the
trial judge bumble ttan this movie's not
happy giving me the finger wants to also
shove that finger up my butthole Barry
be Benson versus the honey industry you
can sue a whole industry I'm kidding I'm
kidding
yes your honor we're ready to proceed
the whole world was waiting to hear Abby
talk for the first time but now that
it's happened they could care less your
opening statement please
this movie is basically the non-holiday
Miracle on 34th Street for bees that was
actually probably the whole pitch but
since it was coming from Jerry Seinfeld
the studio execs didn't pay much
attention to the words and just threw
cash items mr. Klaus van der Heyden of
Honey Farm Berry told us earlier that
flying is exhausting but he's hovering
during this examination instead of
standing can this movie ever follow its
own logic Halliburton and Enron jokes
always slip you mean like this even in a
fictitious world where bees are allowed
to sue humans for taking their honey I
refuse to concede that the judge would
allow a live bear into the courtroom
honestly this film could be brilliant if
interpreted as a satire in the state of
the American legal system have you ever
been stung mr. sting a fucking sting
cameo because his name is sting and this
is a movie about bees how did Jerry
Seinfeld have any credibility after this
movie thank you Ray Liotta lampooning
himself is worthless in off even in a
movie this both articles visible in this
issue of variety have lorne it some
texts also Tom Jones it's not on you you
want to write articles for variety also
also this New York Times is from 2007
this New York Post is from 2004 and this
variety is from 2005 but they're somehow
covering the exact same current events
are we doing everything right you know
legally I'm a florist
I'll take conversations that should have
happened days ago for 600 Alex you think
I don't see what you're doing
okay I'll point out the obvious here and
note that Ken is scared of losing his
girlfriend to a f--king B which is
goddamn insane but the fact that he's
literally threatening the bastard
knowing full well that Barry will tell
Vanessa is even insane er
not as much huh ken went from jealous
boyfriend to full-on pyromaniac in
seconds flat berry isn't able to get out
of the water and fly away but he is able
to grab a nail file and surf on it also
I wonder if he'll tell Vanessa where
that file has been it happens to be the
nicest bee I've met in a long time are
there other bugs in your life this is an
excellent but unsatisfactorily answered
question wait a minute listen this
movie's gone completely off the rails
but the main issue here is that Adam
isn't objecting to this line of
questioning and that Judge Oprah is
letting this fucking circus play out in
our courtroom you're out of order
so trial is out of order now the movie
is claiming that in addition to being
food for the bees honey is also their
blood movie sauce Toy Story and may the
laziest choices possible while trying to
imitate it why is Adam in a human
hospital shouldn't he be back at the
high where they have the actual tools to
heal him what do you think the humans
will do to us if they win
well you sued them so probably not much
the honey companies are essentially
defending themselves against a pretty
species fucking lawsuit and assuming
you've done step 29 correctly you're
ready for the tub judge somehow did not
throw Adam in jail for contempt of court
25 steps ago living out our lives as
honey slaves to the white man what but
this is a jury trial can you just stop a
legal proceeding midway through and
declare a winner is this justice wait
for my signal take him out
I know Barry won his court case but
because of that they're letting him
command an ATF squad b-movie
inadvertently invented fidget spinners
so is this a normal race style workers
uprising or moral fable about the
pursuit of ultimately selfish goals that
appear to be for the good of the many or
is it still about a bee bro trying to
bone a human lady why the hell wouldn't
Vanessa talk to Barry about the lack of
pollination long before she ran out of
flowers they're still seeing each other
right holy not only to Barry but get
this entire urban hell skate
he must have eliminated the entire human
population I made a huge mistake this is
a total disaster and it's all my fault
Jesus Christ he took out the repetition
and the non-sequiturs I swear to god
this movie would be 13 minutes long
looks like we're gonna be experiencing a
couple of hours delay Barry these are
cut flowers with no water
bacon really didn't think I could care
about something less than the
relationship between these two but the
plot twists at the end of this movie are
making a really good case train pilot is
one of the only motherfuckers in this
movie to freak out over a B haven't we
been through this already
Perry's been all over the fucking noobs
somehow this movie is going to end on an
action scene with the flower shop girl
who talks to bees landing a plane and
it's like 15th on the list is stupid
this movie is slung at us now attempting
to land a plane loaded with people
flowers and an incapacitated flight crew
how the fuck did the B news get this
information so quickly is there a
Richard Thornberg up on that plane on a
phone leaking details to the press
[Music]
this works they chant for Barry to think
like a bee and then he tells flower girl
to bring the nose of the plane down but
she's not flying the plane the million
bees carrying it all what the hell is
going on what in the world is on the
tarmac it takes air traffic control this
looking long to notice that one of the
runways has been infested with bees
Barry you've earned this not only did
the pollen jocks remember to bring an
extra uniform it's specifically in Barry
sighs what what where I didn't this is
still going on wait the bees that
surrounded a complain and we're numerous
enough to form a target on the tarmac
all came from one hive in Central Park
even Barry refer to the flower on the
tarmac as consisting of millions of bees
that is so not how pollen works you
think a movie that wants to have an
environmental message would at least
take a quick peek at science somewhere
along the way milk cream cheese so all
the animals can talk and we're just
finding this out now and he's a bee
you're a goddamn cow did you even get
out of your pasture to come here he's a
lawyer too ma'am I was already a blood
sucking parasite all I needed was a
briefcase this movie had four
screenwriters can we squeeze in a joke
about a priest a rabbi and a preacher
into this cliche fest before it's over I
just checked in thankfully only 21
seconds
[Music]
my mouth I've been out in one job
forever that's an insane choice to have
to make you're a very nice guy but I
just don't have any room in my life for
a new friend is it necessary for me to
drink my own urine
no when I do it anyway because sterile
and I like the taste you have got to
start thinking be my friend thinking be
oh not the best
a black yellow black Oh black and yellow
oh we just came up for the funeral we're
marvin kessler he went too early he was
96 years old
welcome to regal entertainment kid is
back on the escalator again
[Music]